we hosted the first ever open source AI
game champ where you had 48 hours to
make a game using at least one open
source AI tool either in the game or in
the Game Dev workflow you also had to
follow a theme which in this Jam was
expanding 88 teams submitted games
making this the largest ever AI Focus
game champ so thank you so much for
participating and making this Jam a
success so let's see what you made you
used AI for tons of different categories
with the most common being as tools in
the development process for art coding
and music with the most popular models
being stable diffusion Chad GPT
mid-journey and music gen but some of
you went all in on AI like in
Singularity where everything that you
see is generated in real time using
stable diffusion with d4m or word
Conquest which uses word embeddings to
make a fun challenging and competitive
vocabulary expansion game or a handful
of games that went into the frontier of
AI with AI NPCs like ever-changing quest
which has AI generated quests NPC
dialogue items the world itself and even
the voices in this Village you have many
tasks before you you may wish to visit
local shops stock up on supplies the
scope is incredible in this game as well
as a handful of others showcase the
incredible potential of what's to come
in the near future but what about where
AI is right now well we've crunched the
numbers and the answer is clear it's art
with over two-thirds of submissions
using AI for art some uses were really
creative like snippet have you ever
wondered what's behind these people now
you can find out but not everyone use
generative AI in fact one of the top
rated games used genetic algorithms to
simulate rabbits a winner after careful
deliberation our three judges
unanimously agreed that the winner of
the first ever open source AI game Jam
ranked first in creativity and overall
is snippet in snippet you jump into
paintings Mario 64 style cut apart the
paintings revealing the AI generated
story behind them and solving puzzles to
move on to the next one it's a super
creative use of AI and really fun to
play congratulations and thank you all
for participating in the first ever open
source AI game Champs see you at the
next one